les enfants demandent des cadeaux sans
trop se soucier de l'inflation
les parents feront de leur mieux je
travaille le jour je commence mes
vacances aujourd'hui la pression là
c'est aujourd'hui et demain c'est le
dernier sprint pour les emplettes des
fêtes
à trois jours de Noël les rabais de 50%
et plus nous rappelle presque le Boxing
d les affaires tournent au ralenti pour
se bijoutier 50% parce que là ça a
commencé très lentement donc on a je
pense que je suis pas le seul mais
beaucoup de commerçants ont déjà
commencé à faire des promotions on a vu
sur beaucoup plus tôt dans l'année plus
longue période de magazine âge où les
gens recherchent des rabais plus d'un
Canadien sur deux planifie réduire ses
dépenses pendant la période des fêtes
qui chuteront de 17% cette année pour
atteindre 1520$ par ménage inflation
coût des aliments et problèmes
économiques forcent les Canadiens à se
serrer la ceinture et on va souvent de
leur amour
les commerçants eux n'ont pas bénéficié
des recettes espérées du vendredi fou et
du cyber lundi et comme les gens entre
le plus de temps cette année pour
réfléchir donc les SPA autant d'achat
qu'on aurait souhaité cette année
pendant ces deux jours là il faut donc
offrir des rabais plus à les champs
[Musique]
et pour attirer la clientèle au Boxing
Day les experts s'entendent pour dire
que les commerçants devront offrir des
rabais plus musclés cette année ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal